hey it's evan and today i'm doing
another one of my Fiverr gigs where i'm
reviewing a website and helping out an
entrepreneur today we are looking at a
touch of wellness VI calm so we're going
to check it out give some feedback and
see how we can help so the first thing I
look at here is I don't really know what
this company does so there's no logo
here there's no value statement there's
some banners coming across the top but
I'd love to see an identity for the
business to let me know here's who we
are what we do what we stand for okay
that's that should be across the top and
give me that feeling right as I hit the
home page and really should be on every
page you've got all these numbers here
at the top I don't know what that means
maybe that's a coding error or whatever
but I definitely get that looked at to
reading down below silver John's most
complete most complete so again like
this is kind of a struggle for him
trying to figure out what you do the
banners are changing most complete
natural health center okay so you do
massage health he has some products in
st. Thomas okay great again like I'm
kind of digging here the ship II this
should hit me right away I should be
able to quickly know what it is that you
do and not have to think about it I'd
love to know who your target market is
is a lot going on on this website
there's a lot to read a lot of places to
look at on this homepage it's kind of
distracting who you trying to go after
you're going after vacationers cruise
travelers you know who is your market
and what do you believe in what makes
you different I don't see any of that
stuff up on here so just cleaning that
up will make it first of a lot easier
for people to come and find you and
understand what you do and tell their
friends and visit more often scrolling
down you some videos it's great what our
clients are saying this is fantastic I
would move this higher I'd also try to
get a picture of these people if
possible this is kind of buried right
you're putting this at the bottom this
is one of the most important things here
it's buried there's no pictures you know
you're relying on somebody to scroll all
the way to the bottom before they read
this where this is super important it
should be higher up
you've got a ton of social media
channels i think that was at the top too
it's a lot and i make sure that these
are always updated only only pick the
ones you're actually using it or being
updated for people to follow you've got
the most common ones taste like twitter
linkedin find google plus you've got the
well let's check these out and check out
we've got flickr we've got pinterest
we've got yahoo let's see what happens
when we load these things up so flickr
you've got 62 photos no following no
testimonials pinterest one board with
four pins yahoo this page isn't even
really working i take this stuff off
it's too cluttered it's too confusing
you're not using it you're not getting
any results from it think about where
you're going to spend your time where
you want to connect with your customers
and actually invest in time into it and
everything else take off the top because
it's not helping you so let's learn more
about this company's click on about us
see what it's all about so I guess the
same banner comes across the top
executive director Jill Lori Scott so
I'm assuming this is Jill it's great
we've got a great picture smiling
personable that's that's perfect widely
known is the massage therapist to the
Hollywood elite Olympic and professional
athletes so this is great now you're
telling me what it is that you do this
should be on your home page because I
was confused at the star didn't know if
you're going after travelers or the
local market who it is you go after
high-end people Hollywood elite Olympic
athletes top business executives around
the world so I need to make sure I
understand that from the top and you're
not relying on people going to your
about Us page because a lot of people
won't even bother going that far so
you've had a lot of experience 30 years
it's great your life's passion firstly
passion about serving your clients and
patients you invested three decades of
your life and thousands of dollars on
the cutting edge of any and all health
related matters this could be stronger
ok this is the about Us page I want to
know about Jill why she started this
business what it's all about it's great
that you love serving your clients and
patients you've invested thousands of
dollars in three decades but you're not
telling me anything about you and and
why you started this business and what
you passionately believe in right I want
to come here and learn a story about
Jill and why I need to hire her why why
does she start this
business did she struggle she started it
up that she see a need in the market
that wasn't being served but what's the
story tie me to this this is so business
focused it's a great story it's a great
start you know it's great you have the
picture a lot of people don't even have
that so it's a good start but to make
this better to really stand out to make
people really pay attention to this and
get tied in that's the point right
somebody clicks on your belt page they
want to be tied into the story you have
to make this more personal more more
emotional tell me what you believe in
why why it's important why I should care
about massage what it means to you to
your life and why you started this
company you know that with passion is
going to bring me in want to learn more
I'd also look at doing a video I saw
some videos on your homepage I'd love to
see a video of Jill talking about why
she started this business and what it
means to her and what she does because
again the more people will spend time on
the site and more people relate to jail
the more people know her like her trust
her see as an expert the more people are
going to want to to come in and start up
with her services but this overall is a
definitely a good start let's see what
else we've got here well raving fans
we've got a radio show that's
interesting let's check out this radio
show Jill does a radio show on mind body
health radio can be hurt every wednesday
at one this is great like so Jill's
expertise here is not being showed off
enough it's nowhere on the homepage it's
barely on the about page and this is a
huge opportunity because you want to
highlight the you are a thought leader
that you are an expert in your field
this should be on the homepage that you
have a radio show that I can learn more
about what you believe in right all that
stuff that's on your show is probably
great you're probably passionate you're
probably sharing what you believe needs
to be different about the health
industry and you're slowly changing that
that's got to be front and center that's
got to be something people can quickly
find and learn about and get tied to you
because I guarantee a lot of these other
people have their own massage clinics
st. Thomas are elsewhere don't have a
radio show don't know what they're
talking about or not as big an expert
don't have the kind of clientele that
you do and that's not showing up until I
dig deeper into the site so there's so
much the work here so much that's uh
that's hidden an underexposed you can
really
grow by giving a little bit more
exposure to i'd love to see previous
episodes so there's no way to see grab
jeans weekly show assignments so you
have a test for Candida simple home
candida test i love to hear podcast like
how can i actually listen to this show
i'd love to see your most recent episode
what i do for my show is I record it and
then I post it to youtube and embedded
on my radio page with all the previous
episodes so you can listen to the show
listen to the most recent episode and it
also helps build up your YouTube channel
and your your expert and your popularity
so I like I don't know how to find this
except by waiting for a wednesday at one
o'clock on Virgin Island time and going
here which most people are not going to
take that kind of time to do so you want
to make it easy for them to do and put
the previous shows right here this is
this is a fantastic initiative you guys
have started let's look at one more page
so we've got being touched let's check
out the blog and again i love
encouraging entrepreneurs to share their
thought leadership to share their
opinions to be an expert because when
you're an expert people trust you more
they want to do business with you more
they know that you know what you're
talking about it it's the differentiator
because so many people start up a
business in any industry there's tons in
this in this wellness field who have no
idea what they're talking about and
that's who you're competing against so
you have to be able to show that you
know what you're saying build a loyal
following and get people to come and buy
from you so we've got a blog post here
it looks like it's kind of up to date
which is good a lot of people have blogs
and never update them pouring rain and
Virgin Islands for the next six days 18
things to do special blog posts of
Virgin Island locals okay so you know
you want to think about your target
market again from your about page I saw
you working with Hollywood celebrities
you're working with executive business
people people with a lot of money high
rollers who are travelers so this is a
post for Virgil and locals that's not
really a market this is the first thing
I see when I come to your blog that's
not what I want to see you want to
create content that is related to your
target audience and share your opinion
let's see what else we got is good
school
down a little bit you're targeting guys
with a lot of money you targeting guys
who want to see you as professional and
part of that is going to have a
professional image right so you want
your website to look good you want your
website to reflect the image you're
trying to create you've got this thing
on the side here CNN top stories I don't
know why you're showing CNN stories on
your website how it relates and it's
breaking your site right you're coming
over the side it doesn't look good it's
talking about blame rape victims for
drinking like how does that have to do
with health and wellness in the Virgin
Islands it's confusing it's not related
I take all that stuff off let's go see
your next one you're talking about sell
replacement program I don't even know
what that is but this could be a great
potential topic what I would do for each
post that your writing is have an
opinion on it right you started this
business for a reason you want to
educate your clients you are the expert
you want to share your strong opinion in
every post that you create and you want
to build up a following of people who
look to you as the trusted guide for
this okay the blog again here since you
are keeping it up-to-date is great you
want to have some exposure for it it's
kind of buried right you're like you're
expecting somebody to click on be in
touch and then go down to blog the only
option here is blog so put blog up top
or put a link to it from your homepage
to make it easy for people to find you
you've got a lot of stuff going on and
that's that's kind of a theme I guess
across your site right your homepage is
busy you're your social media stuff is
busy you've got tons of knobs here with
lots of drop-down options it's all busy
and when it's busy it's harder for the
customer to have a good experience
navigating your site so I would crunch
everything down eliminate all the
distractions make it super easy make the
experience great for the people who are
coming to your website make it easy
people understand what you're doing and
you'll start making more sales and get
more people talking about you overall
it's a great start you're ahead of most
people the design is nice going up
against your competition you'll stand
out more than most people in this
business but you should with your
expertise with the background you have
with the people you've helped with the
show you're doing all the stuff that
you're working on speaks to excellence
and that needs to be shown more
with the website and when you do that
you'll be able to drive a lot more
traffic and a lot more sales believe I
hope that helped Jill for those of you
guys watching like the video please give
it a thumbs up below makes want to do
more if you have a question or comment
about this video leave it below I'll do
a video response if you have a question
for your business thank you guys so much
and I will see you soon